right are we ready folks
good good evening members and officers
of the council and members of the public
welcome to this meeting the standards
committee
bit of housekeeping if the fire alarm is
activated please vacate the offices via
the slurs either through the security
door to the left of the chairman or
opposite the lifts in the foyer please
do not use the stairs and please
assemble on the greeny holy Square where
officers will assist you and advise when
it's deemed safe to return to the
chamber
does anyone intend filming the meeting
any member of the public who objects
with possibility tax doesn't apply
please note this meeting has been live
streamed for members of the public
except for any item of business we're
exempt or confidential information is
considered following the exclusion of
the press and public from the meeting
this meeting is also being recorded and
we've broadcast on the council's YouTube
site
mobile phones can anybody everybody
ensure that your mobile phones are
either turned off or turned to silent
and please don't do not make or receive
calls in the chamber while the meeting
is in progress
and is there any member who wants to
speak under 20.1
no
apologies have been received from
councilor Crow Brown do we have any
other apologies
as he sent it in you know he's on the
list yeah but there's a couple not here
as well
how was he
foreign
cup
apologies
minutes of the meeting held on the 10th
of March I move that the minutes of the
meeting held on the 10th of March be
approved and signed as a correct record
I have a second to please
councilor scoby
unless anyone objects to the minutes I
will take them as agreed
thank you
are there any Declarations of Interest
right as far as the Chairman's report is
concerned it's just a very short verbal
one
um since we last met in March obviously
a couple of small things that have
happened which are all outlined on the
summary of cases and referrals on the
back of all the papers you've got this
evening there's only one thing I want to
mention and I'd like to seek your
support for it and that is yet again
people are complaining about
members using the name counselor in
front of their name on Facebook
and this is obviously causing lots of
members of the public to believe that
they are speaking as a counselor
when in fact they're not and I'm sure
you all know that if there is a breach
then you know the counselor has got to
be acting as a counselor
and I'm I put it in my annual report
every year
and obviously it will be going again in
the report next year but could I seek
your support for that recommendation
please
can I have a proposal
thank you Jill councilor Beckford
secondary
councilor fellows thank you very much
apart from that there's not a lot else
for me to say at this stage we've got a
bit of a busy meeting this evening
so I think we can move straight on to
item agenda
five
and I think Samira is going to open the
discussion
thank you chair
to the first report
before yourself tonight is the amendment
to the councilor's code of conduct you
already have as you're a very
comprehensive code of conduct which has
been adopted by the TDC committee
and following the lgas revised
guidelines which was published recently
what this report is presenting is the
amendment further amendments to the code
of conduct
if I could refer members to page
3 which is number two onwards council is
called a conduct that sets out in a
table format exactly what the changes
are proposed in the actual document
itself
um
sorry I had the old yeah if you could
help me page nine sorry check
it starts off with number two
counselor's code of conduct it's a table
format
so that's the um changes that's actually
used for poles that will be made to the
current code of conduct form and I don't
propose to go into detail individually
but I would say that the you also have
the can code of conduct attached to the
actual report itself and what we've done
is highlighted where the changes should
appear so the yellow is where the
changes will actually come so you you
can actually see for yourself where the
changes needs to be made and if members
are happy to accept those changes as set
out we can make that document a
comprehensive story
papers you've got they've got the yellow
highlighter
um yeah it was on the Constitutional
review party papers that I had and this
one is just
it's also on the agenda on the publish
agenda is highlighted there
not a problem I can take members through
Page by Page it's not a problem at all
okay so if you look at the uh
[Music]
um
TDC code of conduct for members if you
the first changes appears hopefully
maybe with me is under
number one the code and if you go
to roses other significant interests on
the second page
yeah apologize I thought that the agenda
also had the highlighted so
hmm
what's happening
this a gender item five
um
page 11 to cancel the code of conduct
and you'll see a table underneath and
it's the bottom one on page 11.
other significant interests
have you opened it yet yeah
see it's under the code and it's the
second page of the same code and it
refers to where it says other
significant interest
okay
really apologize for that I thought it
had been but I'll look into that anyway
so to be adding the word to a greater
extent than the majority of uh and then
it goes on to say other Council
taxpayers rate payers on inhabitants of
the Electoral division or forward as the
case may be affected by the decision or
in other cases other Council taxpayers
rate payers or inhabitants of the
authority area or so these are the words
that we've added in as a result of the
changes
so that's the first one the second one
is on the same page you'll be pleased to
know it's in the scope and we're adding
number two which says the code applies
to all form of communication and
introduction including social media
then over the page where is the general
obligation is everybody with me so far
good okay so General Obligations under
two small one and small twos been added
which starts off the advisory
conciliation and arbitration which is
known as the acas
those words are adding in
then on the same same heading we go over
to the other page and it's under G no h
under h
um just after H we're adding another
three and a four the three reads where
you have not undertaken training related
to conduct matters you should not be
able to to use this as a defense where
the complaint has been made that's
basically where for example you're
sitting on a planning committee and you
then say that oh I've not I've not
actually had training so I didn't know
so that's not an excuse so we've added
that in specially because we've had
quite a few issues there
um and then the other thing that we've
added is you must cooperate with any
code of conduct investigation and or
determination so as an obligation on
each member if there is an investigation
for them to be fully participant in it
and
advice accordingly
and I think you'd be pleased to know
that's the only that's all there is
that's all the Amendments that's been
suggested
is there any more
where we currently run it
sorry can I add in here I was just going
to say chair that wasn't the actual Ken
secretaries or the oga that was the
recommendation from the Constitution
working party those two recommendations
been added from them because as I set
out in there that if we actually went to
the cwp on the 1st of September and they
increased the gift and Hospitality to
100 pounds and they added the other bit
so it's their recommendation and it's up
to yourselves if you take those
recommendations so it's entirely your
decision so in your hands but that's the
recommendation
I'm totally against a hundred pounds I
think 25 pounds is too much I think
accepting any more than a cup of tea in
a Biscuit we shouldn't be doing
Council bayford yeah thank you good
explain what the rationale behind the
change is I can't really understand why
we would want to make it higher
yeah I yes I can explain that
um basically members at the cwp felt
that some of the gift and Hospitality
they receive far exceeds at 25 pound so
for example if they offer the dinner out
or they take a bottle of champagne or
something so that far exceeds 25 pounds
so then it's better to increase that
limit to 100 rather than having to not
do that that was the rationale behind it
thank you in which case I tend to agree
with councilor scoby thank you
the questions
with the um
the options
we obviously have a choice on each
option that's been added the
recommendations of the Constitutional
review working party
so we should take some sort of vote I
believe on each option yeah if members
are not in agreement then you'll have to
go for a vote
um but this is the recommended decision
from the cwp but at the end of the day
you have the authority to make a
decision and say yes we'll accept those
recommendations or no we reject them
I think if you look at
sorry cancer
oh sorry I just wanted to agree uh it
should remain unchanged at 25 on the
same basis but I just wanted to say that
thank you
if you look at Options under four on
well it says page 14 it could be
anywhere
um
four one is the standard committee can
agree with the recommendations or
suggest further amendments to those
proposed in the report
these could be in addition to those
suggested or amended or amendments to
the suggested changes
then 4-2 is the standards committee
could suggest not making any amendments
to the existing code of conduct however
this is not recommended as it would mean
that TDC have moved away from The Wider
Kent code and the LGA model code of
conduct
so so there we have it
can I just explain to you a little bit
further I think the second
recommendation relates to the actual
code of conduct itself which is what
I've read uh the the the two
recommendations from the cwps within
your Authority so you can make that
decision but it's the rest of the
document that you really recommended
that you should up
Council scoby
yeah I'm quite happy with the the rest
of the document it's just I think even
25 pounds is is too high a limit
and why are we accepting bottles of
champagne and things yeah
in that case from what people you're
saying is the proposition that you
accept the code of conduct changes with
the exception of the gifts and
hospitalities and you feel it should
still remain at 25 pounds
could I have a seconder for that please
those in favor
those in favor
those against
absolutions
to have sentience and six in favor
that's carried
yes thank you chair thank you for that
the next report I'm glad you got me for
the whole night
so the next report is the revised
councilor's complaints handling
arrangement
um again you already have the complaints
the company's handling procedures in in
embedded in the organization and what
the report is actually proposing are the
relevant changes that need to be made
into being in light of the lgas and
other
changes that are happening so again what
we've done on and I appreciate people
have done have the same page numbers as
me and in this instance there's quite a
lot of changes that's been proposed to
the complaints procedure so um I don't
know how members wish me to proceed with
that
foreign
individually
I'm happy to do whatever members wants
me to I can take
um each
let's
I'm happy to do so I don't have enough
problem with that
before we do that just to say that it's
been to the cwp party as well already
and I don't believe they made any
changes
foreign
yeah there was just one changed mate all
suggested by them that the investigating
officer would notify the subject and the
complaint to the appointment with intern
before it was 10 working days that we'd
had to appoint once we get the
investigating officer to get the
decision out they changed it to 20 days
or they proposed that we should change
it to 20 days that's one of the changes
that they wanted to suggest but I'm
happy to go through the other changes I
set out on paper all members can I'm
happy to take questions so I'm in your
hands members are still what you want me
to do
does any member wish to comment on the
let's start with I sat behind someone
almost out of your site I think
um I just wanted to if we could look at
the extension of the number of days
because I think we objected to that
before being increased if I remember
rightly
I'm not I'm not aware of any objection
we discussed increasing the number of
days before I'm not even sure
I might not be remembering it very well
but we did in in discuss increasing the
number of days for complaints and we
rejected it before
is how I remember it now if other people
remember it differently then fair enough
but that's what I'm remembering and
that's the one I'd like to go back over
um it's your recommendations it's your
it's your committee so if you want to go
back to the original then fine we can
look at that it's not a problem
sorry Chad I just wondered what the
reasoning was behind for extending from
10 to 20. yeah I can explain what
happens is one investigation once it's
gone through the um initial screening
test it takes the we have up to 10 days
basically to get investigating off this
front board to actually start the
investigation sometimes people have
other priorities and they're not able to
come on within that 10 days so which is
why it's extended to 20 days so then we
could have a bit longer to be able to do
that that's the reason behind it because
everybody's busy so it's just trying to
give the investigating officer a bit
more time and if you've got a complex
matter in hand then it does take more
than that time to to find a suitable
person to actually do the investigation
for example I've got one that's coming
today which is quite a lengthy complaint
and it will need quite a lot of reading
around it so that will probably will be
quite a lot of time so just an example
of the reason why we wanted to increase
it
if if I could just add the as it says in
the column for reasoning apparently
there is a lack of availability of
suitably qualified investigators
and I understand that is county-wide so
that was one of the other reasons behind
it as well
if I may I think the issue we had before
was the impact on those who are involved
in the additional delay in locating an
investigating officer I think that if I
recall that was the issue
I think my memory serves me right that
was one of the issues that was raised
but of course
to get the need to get over the
investigator first before they can tell
the member that they are under
investigation and it's the getting old
of the investigator that is the problem
so I think I don't think it would be
fair to tell the member they've been
under investigation when at that stage
there's not even an investigator been
appointed
I mean just to assist members you know
if you feel happy to amend it we could
do it for the first year and then bring
it back or I could bring it back in six
months and say this is how it's
progressed so far and if you needed it
review we can this is not set in Stones
this is a working document so if members
feels that they want me to bring it back
in six months I can do that
cancer scoby
yes I think pragmatically we're going to
have to go with the 20 days but ideally
it should be
10 days no it should be 10 days but
because otherwise you're playing with
people's lives and careers sometimes
but pragmatically if we haven't got
the number of Staff we used to have
and qualified people and getting hold of
um having been involved in idsc I know
how difficult it was getting hold of
independent people to investigate for
that so I have sympathy with the need
for 20 days but
um I would prefer at some point in the
future that it goes back to 10 but
pragmatically here and now I'm happy
with it
I don't know if it's mine's a typo but
the actual recommendation is within 30
days not 20.
on the document that I've got
under the investigating deadline
it says if the Monarch officer decides
that the complaint merits form of
Investigation they will normally within
30 working days
whether you've got the same document I
don't know
page 30 item agenda 6.
the bottom paragraph on the left at the
bottom
with the provisions is that the
notification by investigation that's the
proposed amendment is that the
monitoring officer if he decides to
complaint merit's formal investigation
they will normally within 30 days
appoint an investigator to undertake the
investigation and inform parties of the
appointment that is the proposed
amendment that they are seeking
foreign
excuse me we're looking at two different
bits because if you go over to the 2.3
procedure for investigating the
complaint yeah that's the one I was
looking at
notifications by investigating officer
yeah
yeah yes it's they're saying 30. but
they're saying 20. yeah
so
foreign
suggest that you want to make it
consistent those 20 days or 30 days
because it's obviously an error between
the two elements of it
it's it's been referred to the standards
from the crwp for us to approve to then
put to full Council for them to approve
it that's the normal process so if we're
not happy with it then we can send it
back to KCC I believe is
the author of the The Amendments uh
nature it's your Authority you can make
changes and this is this is your
document so you don't have to adopt
anything if you're not happy with if you
want to make changes you can do so
KCC is the obviously they they want us
to take their um example on board but at
the end of the day you are your own
master so you if you say this is not
what we want to do then that's what
you've got to do you've got you can
amend as you as you selfish
in that case first of all can we take
2.11
investigation deadline
where that says 30 days
let's do with that one first is there a
proposal in relation to changing that
not accepting it
can I have a proposal
but
um the increase from 10 to 30 is too
great I would reject it
so do we have a proposal
yeah we'll reject it yeah an automation
oh an alteration 20. I'll accept the 20
the alteration will be 20.
could I have a second
okay
I'm sorry
yeah from here
Council Dexter could you remember to use
your microphone please
it's only for the recording purposes I
think oh
yeah so we're actually recommending
tonight and not approving
yes
so I think now we want to move on to
3.1
notification by investigating officer
can I have
observations from Members please
I I propose we accept that
do I have a seconder
Council bayford
those in favor
excellent
so just to be clear we're changing bowls
to 20 days yes okay that's fine okay
chair I know we didn't get to go through
each of the Amendments but I think it'd
be prudent if I just say that there are
various annexes attached to the report
and next one I know what I'll do is I'll
just highlight what the annexes are so
at least you get a sort of an idea as to
what you what you're recommending to the
full Council the first one is the
arrangement for handling with the code
of conduct under the localism act so the
procedure is is there and then we've
obviously highlighted some of the
changes what I might do is if members
are happy I'm happy to
circulate the highlighted changes so
then members that can actually see and
if there's any queries please do come
back to me straight away
um right because there's quite a lot of
changes and and if I started doing that
I think you probably all get bored and
tired of me speaking
um then you've got the annex 2 which is
the procedure on the seat of a complaint
which again sets out and there are a
couple of changes that have been
proposed and and made as well
in relation to the sanctions as well
then you've got the new complaints form
which is online so if anybody wants to
complain they need to do it online and
the form is there and it's all
electronic and it takes you through tabs
it's it's quite a good form to do so in
relation to that I'm sorry can I
interrupt there
is this for Council people doing it
online or members of the public
because a lot of my constituents do not
have computers do not have mobile phone
do not have access to the internet so we
would be depriving probably 30 of
cliftonville West residents of being
able to do it if they wanted to which is
highly unlikely
um it doesn't stop people complaining um
we can take complaints in writing as
well I've had two complaints where
people at least physically written
letters or complain so the ideal
situation is to use the electronic form
if they can if they don't have a success
to it we will take complaints by writing
it's not a problem
yes Michael just wondered if the
procedure because it's public if it
could be plain English in any way
because I was reading it through feeling
it was quite challenging
to make your way through it and the form
is the form is helpful it could be a
little bit less jargony in places but
just if there's I know it's a
standardized set of words from LGA and
from Kent but if there's anywhere
getting that plain English I think that
would be helpful to complainants as well
I'll certainly have a look at it but
this is the recommended as you quite
rightly said by the LGA and the can
secretary groups and KCC if I can put it
like they've also looked at it and that
is their standard word
I just thought it might be worth raising
it's a futuristic with them because it
is very you follow it through and it's
quite complex in terms of the steps you
have to go through and the sort of you
go one way and then you go another way
because you can't make a complaint in
one particular way and I think it would
help everyone if it was if it was easy
to understand
I'm happy to look at it again chair if
the if members want to meet you that's
not a problem
I think yes but I think to answer that
um
the notification of Complaint to
the monitoring officer of the council
I don't think has changed to be honest
um the only thing is
I don't think it's in the public domain
what the jurisdiction test is
uh I were their counselor at the time is
it about another counselor and the
jurisdiction test I don't think is
available to the public I might be wrong
do you know Samir
see the best of my knowledge there is
something on the website but I can't
verbatimely confirmed that definitely is
there
um what I did propose with member
services was to do a flow chart
in relating to the jurisdiction test and
then members of the public and us as
officers as well can follow it easily as
opposed to going through rooms and reams
of papers so that was something that I
will need to discuss it with Nick and
get something set up if the members if
that would assist public members in
terms of following where the complaint
goes so if he comes in he goes well and
so forth and that would help people to
understand what the JT was
I'm am I just writing thinking if a
member of the public
wrote a letter of complaint
would they would the office lift from
that letter of complaint the details to
fill into the Complaint Form that's
online that everybody would use
too tedious for us to do that we'll just
basically take the complaint as written
down on paper I have queried one once
and twice in terms of what the breach
has been so I've gone back to the public
and said can you please explain what the
council's breach is and then
investigated accordingly but um because
the members of the public once they've
written a letter it's not fair for us to
go back and say can you know for us
didn't put it on there because then
there's there's too many questions that
needs to be filled in
Council dealt with
um can I just clarify we're talking
about using online complaint forms and
putting complaints in writing is there
an option for telephone complaints for
the people for whom those both of those
options would be difficult
yes people do we do we've got a um
I think it's One Stop Shop
um
I'm not familiar with exactly who takes
the complaints but I have had the
executive groups inform me on a couple
of um what they call the Frontline
complaints so yes there is option there
that people can complain and phone in
and say can the monitoring officer
contact me I've got a complaint to raise
so yeah that is the possibility as well
but the procedure that we're trying to
go down the rate of and I appreciate
that a lot of the public don't have
access to the computers and online and
stuff is to them to do the online
complaints because then we can keep a
track of what's going on and have a
manual record but I appreciate we're not
there and it's it's a work in progress
and hopefully if we introduce that now
people will get the gist of it
eventually and then they'll start
filling forms you know doing you know
Finding other ways of actually putting a
complaining but it doesn't stop people
complaining trust me just because they
can't feel the forming you'd get a
telephone call you'll get people even
turn it up at the doorstep downstairs
and say I need to raise a complaint or
telephone so yeah I get complaints from
All Sorts so about restaurant
streamlined to see whether we can do
that but
it doesn't stop
Council bayford
um yes I mean I think changing the word
in document may be not be easy I'm sure
it's been considered very carefully
um not to allow any ambiguity or
anything else like but I do think the
inclusion of a flowchart would be a good
clear
um
way for members of public to follow
I think that was a very very good
suggestion thank you
thank you no problem I know that the
next is the annex 3 which is the
procedure for investigating the
complaints and this is the bit where I
sort of hesitated as I'm taking because
it's literally full of all the
highlighters and all the changes that we
need to make
um so we've changed uh introduced
referring cases back to the monitoring
officer evidence of new breaches and
deferring it for investigation so it's a
sort of detailed in terms of how the
investigation is going to take place
what process and
um whatever it is how we're going to
gather the evidence and who's going to
do what so this is where quite a lot of
the changes are actually happening
and the last I believe is the last one
and the next one is the hearing panel
procedure so if the investigation's been
carried out and it proceeds to the
hearing panel what procedures we're
going to follow
um there's a couple of amendments that's
been suggested there as well one of the
key ones that we've added is the right
to accompany by representative so the
subject matter can choose to bring a
council a solicitor or any other person
they may wish to do so the
the LGA obviously is it's their
recommendation and quite a lot of
authorities have actually accepted that
because it's right to a fair trial and
sort of that kind of representation so
that's that's in there now
um
um and there's some other changes as
well and I believe
that's it that's all the annexes that I
need you to draw your attention to
because obviously this is going to go to
council and um as I said I'm happy to
circulate the highlighted
um changes and then members can actually
see and if they've got any queries
please feel free to come back to me with
the other amendmental suggestions or
alternatives
thank you
I think first of all that would be a
good idea because then I think everybody
will be on the same page when they start
reading it so we're not jumping from
different pages and I think that that
would probably work a treat
cancer fellows yeah thank you
um it's very comprehensive process
investigating and complaints and
looking at what we can do but when you
go to Annex 4 section 12 really
there's not a lot not a lot we're going
to do
if there's a breach or you know or I
mean we've had some awful things happen
with councils in the past and when you
look at 12.4 it says the hearing power
has no power to suspend or disqualify a
member
you know that we're just not giving this
panel any teeth
to a basic counselor who's not got any
responsibilities or a leader of the
council
when it's found to be in breach shift
conduct
has no sanction really
as far as I'm concerned we have Mr
Pickles to thank for that he he
um withdrew all the powers at standards
committee
uh did have and I think if you remember
only three four years ago we had to come
to council with a motion to censure a
member
and that that caused a little bit of a
fewer as well so unfortunately our hands
are tied we just have to go to the
leaders of the relevant parties and seek
their cooperation
that's why I say I mean we've got
comprehensive
process of dealing with complaints about
the end of the day
well generally all we get to do is just
yeah slap on the wrist or get someone to
make a letter of an apology which some
people you know do some quite drastic
things as we've seen in the past and
I've been at the end I I understand that
the LGA were looking at this to try to
reinstate some sort of powers
um out that's some months ago now so how
far they've got down that road with
everything that's been going on in the
country I don't know
unfortunately
to cover both items agenda items five
and six
chair can be a greater recommendation
before we move on to the next
recommendations from the standards
committee
foreign
Council regarding the amended standard
complaints arrangements so basically
this is for Council to endorse but with
your recommendation
I think we've covered proposals on both
items Council scoby
I think we've covered everything that
we want to raise
and no doubt um it will either go back
to crwp or go to full Council it might
well go back to crwp first I don't know
I don't know what the processes for
referring it back to them
it will go to full Council
there you have it
can we have a purpose
foreign
I think we've covered it all to be
honest
right item I don't know that you need to
get everyone to agree
does everybody agree
any any objection
any abstention
thank you
the only one I want to ask and I don't
know if anybody here knows the answer
what's the current situation with
um complaint number 273 of 22.
that seems to have been going on for
some time yeah I do I do know about that
one because I dealt with it the other
day
um obviously I can't diverge the
information in terms of who the member
of the public was or anything it was
quite a straightforward complaint and
it'd been outstanding
um my predeceter didn't have the
opportunity to delve into the complaint
um so she wasn't she just ran out of
time I guess so I've dealt with it so it
should not be closed it says I was
standing on it but as of this week it's
been dealt with so it's no longer
outstanding
um while I'm on on this on this chart
what I and with obviously with the
agreement of the chair
um and um you've got the list of all the
complaints which is about 13 and so far
since January I think yes it's January
of this year what other authorities tend
to do is to have a report under the exam
part of the agenda with more details in
terms of what the complaint is and who
the complaint is for or by and then what
the resolution is so then you get a lot
more openness and a lot more
transparency in terms of what the
complaint is because
um that's what members have done in the
other authority so I'm happy to for the
next standards committee to actually
bring a report in the exempt part of the
agenda with more details in it if
members find that beneficial
the only observation I've gone I'm sure
some of you will come back to me on that
is
do your fellow counselors want you to
know that a complaint's been made
against them
I think if complaints will be made
against councilors I think we should uh
should know if they've been upheld at
least if it's been thrown out I think
maybe it's a different thing
you mean the old innocent until proven
guilty
foreign
I
would foresee
um especially if the complaint is not
upheld
because there are certain people who've
had three or four complaints made
against them this that I know of in the
last couple of years were not one has
been upheld now
is that going to leave a stain on that
person's character amongst the rest of
the members and actually council bayford
is not in her head
yes I totally agree I think that if a
complaint is not uphilled I don't think
it should be
okay yeah I agree with that uh
councilman I think if
we get Spirits complaints made again
against oh I I don't believe I have but
I mean we get complaints made against us
it can be you know politically motivated
or whatever you know if it's not upheld
and it's not a complaints
Samir I think that's right that we
should just leave their name off except
for when the cat the complaints upheld
yeah absolutely absolutely we can do
that so I can I can amend that
accordingly it's not
I don't think we need any sort of
proposal or proposal for that's just
something that we're going to present at
the next committee
is there any any of the matters arising
in that case
it's 747 meeting is closed